je vais parler du rapport du Sénat sur
le trafic de stupéfiants en provenance
de la Guyane qui a été rendu en 2020 et
qui préconnaisait un renforcement de la
coopération internationale et notamment
avec le Surinam et vous le savez la
cocaïne qui transite par la Guyane avant
d'arriver en France hexagonale passe
essentiellement par le Surinam donc ma
question est simple pouvez-vous nous
dire où on est la coopération bilatérale
avec le Surinam euh Suriname coopération
avec la Guyane donc avec la Guyane la
l'actualité territoriale de Guyane il y
a un certain nombre de problèmes le
premier est celui de l'UR payage illégal
donc qui est un sujet complexe dans
lequel autant je pense sous le contrôle
de mon collègue les progrès ont été
sensibles avec le Brésil autant avec le
avec le le Surinam et comme l' dit
d'ailleurs la première ministre quand
elle s'est rendue à la frontière le le
31 janvier elle a dit voilà on manque un
peu de volonté politique du côté
surinamé pour faire cesser C ce cet
orpyage illégal avec l'usage du mercure
qui est extrêmement polluant et
pénalisant pour les populations le donc
le Surin nous avons un accord de
coopération policière qui a été ratifié
qui est entré en vigueur en 2017 je donc
théoriquement on peut coopérer c'est un
des obstacles à cette coopération et le
fait que nous avons un accord sur la
frontière sur le le fleuve Moroni sur
les lesons les 2/ers de la frontière qui
n'est pas encore ratifié donc qu'on a
malgré tous nos nos toutes les
assurances qui ont été données par le le
président santokim y compris le
président de la République donc on est
et un dernier tiers à négocier donc on
est sur une quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre du qui n'est pas satisfaisant
qui suppose une volonté politique
partagée du côté du Surinam au-delà des
assurances qui nous sont données le le
Surinam pays de de 700 700000 habitants
euh est confronté à une situation
politique intérieure disons assez
complexe avec une majorité fragile
menacée d'explosion donc ce qui fait que
le Parlement pour différentes raisons
euh ne se saisit pas de de cette de
cette question de la ratification de de
l'accord de frontières donc je pense que
là-dessus c'est d'un pays avec lequel on
a un partenariat avec qu'on souhaite
développer mais on a euh une frustration
euh persistante en ce qui concerne le la
coopération transfrontalière nous
souhaitons mettre en place des
patrouilles mixtes les point de disons
de de frustration également c'est la
question des des migrants illégaux en
qui transitent par le Surinam en
particulier euh à partir d'Haïti donc il
y a un certain n de de charter donc on
nous explique que c'est du regroupement
familial donc la réalité c'est que les
les demande d'asile ont été ont été
multiplié par 3 en Guyane en particulier
des Haïtiens donc on a un vrai problème
qui a été résolu à diverses périodes ce
problème s'est posé au Nicaragua euh le
Nicaragua est un pays de transit de
migrants je pense que les Américains ont
mis bon ordre en en intimant au
compagnies aériennes de cesser ce genre
de pratiqu euh qui aliment euh peut-être
à dessin l'immigration clandestine vers
les États-Unis donc on a nous on la la
Guyane euh pays très vaste euh assez peu
peuplé relativement et avec une
frontière assez longue euh et confronté
à et perméable à ce à ce genre de à ce
genre de menace voilà